[Music]
in that's actually kind of cool news oh
let's hear about that submitted by
Ultron saves the world I've been
watching as a kid who is it what is it
words that so far suffer I read do right
from where what comes out one show with
I don't know screaming Japanese people
sounds like a transformer thing but I
don't know I Rangers is alternate rope
heard of Ultron or is it Ultraman you
came in so confident you're thinking
Voltron a Voltron Oh Voltron I had a
Voltron lunchbox who's that we don't
know anything it was tight look I got
that was Power Rangers when they get
together and they go on that [ __ ]
robot isn't that Voltron
man was arrested for writing a
rollerblade bodysuit between cars
rollerblade bodies rollerblades bodies
lay down he lays down that's scary
that's so scary you go underneath the
cars let me see that [ __ ] you guys want
to guess where this takes place Florida
Japan Florida Japan is that Street luge
or China Street but you know when just
real oozing there's that theme that
[ __ ] they get on that thing the wall
oh no it's forward oh I would say Japan
maybe like you like how they do Mario
Brothers I'm thinking Europe you're the
only one Laura or China I'm waiting to
understand what's going on okay so China
yeah I knew it's gonna be Eastern Europe
we're not gonna celebrate your victory
because we're heaters your heater on me
yeah no I got a right you said China
yeah I said Eastern Europe yeah that's a
super Eastern Europe you should have
just said old-world Asia by the way he
said east of Europe ha very clear east
of Europe it's gonna be not on the keys
I know how you went all date cities very
well but okay hey hey I didn't know
there were team I'm doubling what's
going on
there's always teams Joe why you always
trying to separate [ __ ] she's just
saying what is it is what it is David's
been driving all of us apart God I just
clicked right united we stand
yes we're gonna be big we figured me out
all right
this is the video of this Chinese dude
in the rollerblade suit weaving through
traffic that's too exaggerating always
pushing himself it's actually motorized
oh dude that's kind of scary man that's
oh that's kind of cool actually it's
cool but scared it is very scary
especially the cars like that yeah it's
during traffic that was like rush hour
you think he's like some like superhero
obviously think she's a superhero have
you guys seen the Chinese zodiac wait
what you like the tiger in the 2012
movie you would take a chance
oh no no no Jackie Chan wore a similar
suit why did Jackie where uses the whole
suit to like go through a ton I like how
his back looks like the bottom of a
trash can bucket yes everyone's saying
like he's with Jackie Chan impersonate
that looks kind of fun though all right
I'm not gonna lie I was I was hating but
I want to try it looks cool I just
wanted not a closed course like no cars
around but there's like some crazy turns
we could all race do you guys want to
guess how much this suit is 24 grams six
million three hundred bucks
six thousand I'll say five g's know so
it was fourteen thousand six hundred and
fifteen dollars oh my god one hundred
thousand yuan he designed it from
scratch well I don't know he's a kid
well that person is rich to spend
fourteen thousand dollars that's a lot
of [ __ ] money where do they sell
varnish printers or some [ __ ] no I mean
like if you think about it right
we rode electric skateboard over the
weekend so you strap that [ __ ] on your
chest everything else grab a end of a
mop bucket [ __ ] tie that [ __ ] all
over your body you're done but his looks
way cooler than I know
what about the hand protection handles
an Ironman costume oh that's it I rolled
smash ones on my head yeah there you go
it must be a very bumpy ride yeah could
you imagine you're like oh yeah maybe
that's why they made it so expensive
because it looks like a kind of like the
bottom of a roller blade so his body
fits nicely in there and maybe there was
like hydraulics or something in there
would you if it's that expensive yeah
doesn't really like a skateboard I feel
like the closer you are to the ground
the scarier it is [ __ ] yeah
and closer are two other cars that are
moving and scarier it is but yeah that's
true do you get used to ride skateboards
on your hands and knees as a kid I were
you kick will you kick like this you
[ __ ] ride it and you kick like this
really bad so I was I really held back
on trying to ride like a normal like
standing up for like the longest time
because I was scared me I pictured the
balls became like a more human my story
please alright so I didn't want to learn
how to ride a skateboard the right way
and stand up because I was too scared
until one time my [ __ ] brother
grabbed me and he pushed me the [ __ ]
like down the hill and then I hit the
curb with my mouth and I American
History X to myself when I bit my own
tooth I mean my lip but that's why I got
luscious lips if you want to know the
secret I'm gonna do that today yeah [ __ ]
out of my lips that [ __ ] up but yeah
after that I was like I'm gonna try
standing up and ride the skateboard and
that was a lot less scary I was like oh
there's actually music and you said
you're not that close with your brother
right
that's interesting I don't know seemed
like it would be really cool that I went
down a big hill sitting on the
skateboard and I ain't [ __ ] to do
are like velocity I guess you feel less
control yeah like a joy shake shaking
like a [ __ ] you sat on the
skateboard
yeah scared and it went down a hill
that's more scarier than face yeah yeah
I think so really
no that's not more scary I think yours
are scarier yeah cuz you don't know what
you're gonna hit at least my legs were
right there I couldn't hold on to
something it's very different from like
holding behind like holding behind is
like yeah I think since my face is too
close to there I'm like no I'm not doing
this no I'd rather do this in hold on
this when it snowed I got a big ass
inner tube and my friends we would all
line up on the hill and I would just try
to run them over with my inner tube and
we would all take turns like trying to
dodge it and trying to get run over and
share Oh have you guys ever slipped down
hills with cardboard boxes - is fun the
only sliding I ever did was a slip and
slide but we use like dishes not like
the mala soap on a garbage bag
oh no Anitha no we bought the real one
okay brag about it rich guy what do you
say we bought the real one with the
Gator oh privilege all over our faces
slide you made another garbage bags a
lot thank you
so you hit the bump and then it's like
the Gators thingy Joe and [ __ ] I wanted
to slip and slide so I never had to go
to therapy because I had that I had a
power wheel a TV one
and this the songs day-lewis pow pow pow
TIFF just one of the big wheel get one
no she wanted a big wheel you wanna put
you a big wheel you still fit on it
right now alright you actually I tried I
wanted about that fun my friend had one
it's just like the tires all plastic
it's one of those ways it's like it's
not really going anyone you didn't I
showed you the picture of this dad so he
has his daughter and she had a power and
he souped it up and I think this this
power will can hit up to like 45 miles
per hour yeah I need taught her how to
drift in it so this like this little
chick or this little girl three or four
she would just drift like she'd go
[ __ ] the neighborhood streets yeah
she knew what she was doing
yeah but 45 yeah she's drifting Jesus
she was or the pink I think I saw that
video not sure like she's like health
cute little clumsy yeah I could drift on
the big wheel because the plastic tires
were slidable so you just go really fast
and you've hit it backwards yeah I
didn't know I was drifting no I just
thought it was like cheap though you
have one of the cool Power Wheels like a
Batmobile no I had a ATV the yellow one
follow that yeah I'm not a pogo stick
for Christmas I always but in oh my god
did you get that I did wanna whoo but I
never got one what did you have any
neighbors uh hoola hoops like two
dollars what was your childhood I would
get those like swap meet toys like the
ones that were like like super guys know
like the the makeup kit that would give
[ __ ] oh that's me too
that's what I wanted all those toys I
saw the commercials but I never got any
of them but then my friend he had all
those I got to play with it every once
every other week I lived around other
poor people so they never had anything
did you get it not Stretch Armstrong
it's like he looks like it but he
doesn't stretch uh I don't know if my
[ __ ] was new either I just remember it
just being red like there and built
everyone like
even had a Power Wheels it was a pink
Jeep oh my friend had that one time I
went over my can I please play on it
okay my cousin's all had power wheels so
each one of them I had like four cousins
they all had their own power wheel
because it said whatever the newest
thing was and it had the big old
trampoline
I wanted that my brother every console
had an actual jumper like an inflatable
bounce house I was wondering that had
those race cars like the tiny little
race cars maybe I had an actual battery
and everything they had everything those
are the toys that I had my I wanted to
get Billy everything I saw you wanted
skip it no no yeah everything that I saw
in the commercial that I wanted I never
want I want to keep it to like I wanted
all those my mom bought me a jump rope
they should bought me a trampoline well
trap woods are no they're all like a
functional kid my cousins had arcade
basketball where you like to do that
thing no my cousins I didn't have it you
guys just play with it well yeah but not
for long I had to leave
[Music]
you